what we're going to do in this video is
study a proof of the pythagorean theorem
that was first discovered
first discovered as far as we know first
discovered by james garfield in 1876
and what's exciting about this is he was
not a professional mathematician you
might know james garfield as the 20th
president of the united states he was
elected president
he was elected four years after 18 in
1880 and then he became president in
1881 and he did this proof while he was
a sitting member of the united states
house of representatives and what's
exciting about that it shows that
abraham lincoln was not the only u.s
politician or not the only u.s president
who was really into geometry
and what garfield realized is if you
construct a right triangle so i'm going
to do my best attempt to construct one
so let me construct one right here so
let's say this
side right over here is length b
let's say this side
is length
a
and let's say that this side the
hypotenuse of my right triangle has
length c so i've just constructed
a right triangle and let me make it
clear it is a right triangle he
essentially flipped and rotated this
right triangle to construct another one
that is congruent to the first one
so let me construct that so we're going
to have length b and it's collinear with
length a it's along the same line i
should say
they don't overlap with each other so
this is length side of length b
and then you have a side of length let
me drive it should be a little bit
taller side of length to b
then you have your side of length a
at a right angle
your side of length a comes in at a
right angle
and then you have your side of length c
you have your side
of length
length c
so the first thing we need to think
about is what's the angle between these
two sides
what's this mystery angle what's that
mystery angle going to be
well it looks like something but let's
see if we can prove to ourselves it
really is what we think it looks like
if we look at this original this
original triangle and we call this angle
theta what's this angle over here the
angle that's between sides a of length a
and length c what's this the measure of
this angle going to be
well theta plus this angle have to add
up to 90. because you add those two
together they add up to 90 and then you
have another 90 it's going to get 180
degrees for the for the interior angles
of this triangle
so these two have to add up to 90 this
angle is going to be 90
minus theta
well if this triangle up here is
congruent and we've constructed it so it
is congruent the corresponding angle to
this one is this angle right over here
so this is also going to be theta and
this right over here is going to be 90
minus theta so given that this is theta
this is 90 minus theta what is our angle
going to be
well they all collectively kind of go
180 degrees so you have theta
plus 90 minus theta
plus our mystery angle is going to be
equal to 180 degrees
the
the thetas cancel out theta minus theta
and you have 90 plus our mystery angle
is 180 degrees subtract 90 from both
sides
and you are left with
your mystery angle equaling
90 degrees so that all worked out well
so let me make that clear
let me make that clear and that's going
to be useful for us that's going to be
useful for us in a second
it's going to be useful so we can now
say definitively that this is 90 degrees
this is a right angle
now what we are going to do is we are
going to construct a trapezoid
this side a is parallel to side b down
here the way it's been constructed this
is just one side right over here this
goes straight up and now let's just
connect these two sides right over there
connect to these two sides
right over there
so there's a couple of ways to think
about the area of this trapezoid one is
we can just think of it as a trapezoid
and come up with it with with its area
and then we could think about it as the
the sum of the areas of its components
so let's just think first think of it as
a trapezoid so what do we know about the
area of a trapezoid well the area of a
trapezoid is going to be the height of
the trapezoid which is a plus b
a plus b
that's the height of the trapezoid
times the way i think of it the mean of
the top and the bottom or the average of
the top and the bottom
so plus
plus or so this times
times one half
times a plus a plus b
a
a plus b
a plus b and the intuition there you're
taking the height times the average of
the bait of this bottom and the top the
average of the bottom and the top gives
you the area of the trapezoid
now how can we also figure out the area
with its component parts so this should
be regardless of how we calculate the
area as long as we do correct things we
should come up with the same result
so how else can we come up with this
area well we could say it's the area of
the two
the two right triangles
the area of each of them is one half a
times b
one half a times b
but there's two of them let me do that b
in that same blue color
but there's two of these right triangles
so let's multiply by two
so this two times one half a b that
takes into consideration this bottom
right triangle and this top one
and what's the area of this large one
that i will color in in green
what's the area of this large one
well that's pretty straightforward it's
just one half c times c so plus
one half
c times c which is one half c squared
now let's simplify this thing and see
what we come up with and you might guess
where all of this is going so let's see
what we get
so we can rearrange this so this is one
half let me rearrange this so it's one
half
times
a plus b squared
a
plus b
a plus b squared is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to two times one
half well that's just going to be one so
it's going to be equal to a times b
a times
b plus one half c squared
plus one half c squared well i don't
like these one halves laying around so
let's multiply both sides of this
equation by two
i'm just going to multiply both sides of
this equation by 2 on the left hand side
i'm just left with a plus b squared so
let me write that a
plus b squared plus b squared and on the
right hand side i am left with 2 a b
to
a
b trying to keep the color coding right
and then 2 times 1 half c squared that's
just going to be c squared plus c
squared
well what happens if you multiply out a
plus b times a plus b what is a plus b
squared well it's going to be a squared
plus
plus two a b
plus two
a b
a
b
plus b squared and then our right hand
side
our right hand side is still
is still it's going to be equal to all
of this business and changing all the
colors is difficult for me
so let me copy and let me paste it so
it's still going to be equal to the
right hand side well this is interesting
how can we simplify this is there
anything that we can subtract from both
sides
well sure there is you have a 2 a b on
the left hand side you have a 2 a b on
the right hand side let's subtract 2 a b
from both sides
if you subtract 2 a b from both sides
what are you left with
you are left with the pythagorean
theorem
so you're left with a squared
plus b squared
is equal to
is equal to c squared very very exciting
and for that we have to thank the 20th
president of the united states james
garfield and i really you know this this
is really exciting because this the
pythagorean theorem was around for
thousands of years before james garfield
and he was able to contribute just kind
of fiddling around while he was a member
of the u.s house of representatives